kommt die kernfusion viel schneller als
gedacht kernfusion durch künstliche
blitze ein deutsches forschungsteam hat
jetzt herausgefunden dass sich kern
fusionsprozesse durch extrem starke und
schnelle gepulste elektrische felder
deutlich verstärken lassen könnten
künstliche blitze uns etwa dem weg zur
erfolgreichen kommerziellen kernfusion
ebenen klicks um science and future bis
dreimal pro woche spannendes seien
sowieso abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke ein fantastisches
los geht's
herzlich willkommen
fest steht wir haben ein energie dilemma
und zwar weltweit eine der großen fragen
die fachleute beschäftigt wann wird
endlich fusions strom durch die
leitungen fließen klar scheint zumindest
dass die fusionsenergie die lösung aller
energieprobleme weltweit sein könnte
eine co2 freie energie lösung eine idee
um die energieversorgung der nächsten
generation zu sichern ein entscheidender
beitrag zur globalen energiewende ohne
sicherheitsrisiko eine saubere
unerschöpfliche und kontrollierte
energiequelle mit kernfusion wären wir
also in der lage nahezu unendlich viel
sauberer energie herzustellen und das
wäre wohl der entscheidende schritt im
kampf gegen die klimakrise damit würden
wir wohl den beginn eines neuen
technologie zeitalters einläuten die
fusionstechnik gilt also als eine art
heiliger gerade im energiebereich manche
gehen sogar noch weiter und halten die
fusionsenergie sogar für die einzige
möglichkeit die menschheit vor einer
vernichtenden klimakatastrophe zu
bewahren doch bisher gibt es trotz
intensiver forschung noch einige größere
und kleinere baustellen bis es zur
umsetzung kommen viele fachleute gehen
deswegen davon aus dass
fusionskraftwerke wohl frühestens in
einigen jahrzehnten zur energiewende
beitragen können sprich jetzt müssen wir
erstmal mit windkraft sonnenkraft und
allen anderen erneuerbaren energien
voran schreiten ein deutsches
forschungsteam vom helmholtz-zentrum
dresden-rossendorf hzdr heißt das hat
jetzt eine spannende entdeckung gemacht
gepulste elektrische felder die
beispielsweise durch blitzeinschläge und
verursacht werden könnten die kernfusion
ein großes stück weiter nach vorne
bringen welche vorteile würde das eine
fusionsreaktion bringen und welche
bedingungen müssen geschaffen werden wie
könnten die notwendigen gepulsten
elektrischen felder erzeugt werden die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr natürlich
interessante infos zum thema kernfusion
gibt es jetzt hier von mir keine frage
die fusionsforschung hat viel potenzial
wenn ja wenn sie denn dann funktioniert
denn bei einer kernfusion wird so viel
energie frei wie bei keiner anderen
energiequelle auf atomarer ebene
entstehen dann dabei vereinfacht gesagt
aus zwei leichten atomen ein schweres
atomen die gesamtmasse des neuen atoms
ist aber geringer als die der beiden
einzelnen energie wird frei und zwar
nicht zu wenig ein gramm der brennstoffe
könnte ihnen ein versuchsreaktor so viel
energie liefern wie sie bei achtung der
verbrennung von elf tonnen kohle
entsteht derzeit gibt es zwei große
herausforderungen allerdings neben den
großen finanziellen mitteln die
gebraucht werden ist vor allem die
technik nicht ohne denn wasserstoff
atome verschmelzen nicht einfach so zu
helium denn das ist der prozess die
kerne sind positiv geladen und zwar
immer beide die aufeinandertreffen und
verschmelzen sollen und es gibt eben
eine gegenseitige abstoßung das gas muss
also extrem erhitzt und verdichtet
werden so entsteht dann plasma eine
wolke aus durcheinander fliegende
atomkernen und elektronen dennoch der
große plan ist dass fusionsenergie so
schnell wie möglich kommerziell zu
nutzen und das wäre tatsächlich der
beginn einer neuen ära beim europäischen
versuchs kernfusionsreaktor iter wie man
bis zum jahr 2025 das erste mal
wasserstoff plasma erzeugt haben dass es
aber noch keine infusion das dauert dann
immer auch noch mal ein bisschen das
wird schon seit jahrzehnten daran
gearbeitet die sonne zu imitieren durch
die verschmelzung von wasserstoff atom
will man so energie gewinnen so wie es
eben auch in der sonne passiert dafür
notwendig ist allerdings eine extrem
heiße umgebung denn nur so können sie
schwere atome wie beispielsweise
deuterium und tritium zwei wasserstoff
isotope überhaupt dazu gebracht werden
miteinander zu reagieren normalerweise
stoßen sie sich eben ab eine
entscheidende rolle spielt hierbei der
sogenannte quantenmechanische
tunneleffekt dazu sagt der
wissenschaftler ralph schiphol vom
helmholtz-zentrum dresden-rossendorf
eine folge des thuner effekt ist es dass
gleichartig geladene teilchen ihre
gegenseitige abstoßung überwinden können
auch wenn ihre energie dafür eigentlich
kann ich aus reicht zumindest nicht nach
den gesetzen der klassischen mechanik so
etwas können wir zum beispiel bei der
verschmelzung zweier leichter atomkerne
beobachten je stärker sich ein kern dem
anderen nähert desto größer wird die
abstoßung die wir uns bildlich als einen
sich vor dem kern auftuenden berg
vorstellen können die sogenannte
potenzial barriere anstatt den energie
aufwendigeren weg über den gipfel zu
nehmen erlauben die gesetze der
quantenmechanik dass der kern
energetisch deutlich günstiger
geradewegs durch diesen berg bringt bzw
hindurch tunnelt und schließlich
fusionieren kann kurz zusammengefasst
heißt das also dass die kernfusion wie
sie beispielsweise in der sonne statt
findet erst durch den
quantenmechanischen tunneleffekt
ermöglicht wird übrigens spielt der
tunneleffekt nicht nur in der
quantenwelt eine wichtige rolle sondern
auch im biologischen bereich wie etwa
bei der mutation von gehen es ist also
nicht übertrieben zu sagen dass der
tunnel effekt das leben auf der erde
erst möglich macht der tunneleffekt
spielt in der physik also eine riesige
rolle und so wurde er bereits vor knapp
100 jahren das erste mal beschrieben
dennoch ist dieser spannende vorgang in
vielen details immer noch nicht genau
verstanden die wissenschaft geht davon
aus dass elektrische felder auf
verschiedene art und weise einfluss auf
tunnel prozesse haben könnten unter
anderem könnten sie dafür sorgen dass
die teilchen durch elektrische felder
beschleunigt werden so führen sie zu
mehr energie zudem können sie die
sogenannte tunnel wahrscheinlichkeit
erhöhen und zwar indem sie die
sogenannte potenzial barriere
deformieren eine neue studie von
helmholtz forscher aus dresden zeigt
jetzt welchen effekt elektrische felder
beim kern fusionsprozess haben können
das deutsche forschungsteam konnte
nämlich jetzt nachweisen dass zeitlich
schnell verändernde elektrische felder
dazu in der lage sind teilchen aus der
potenzial barriere heraus zu schubsen
diese können dadurch leichter tunnel zu
dieser neuen erkenntnis kamen die
fachleute unter anderem bei der
fusionsreaktion die auch für eine
mögliche energieerzeugung interessantes
konkret geht es um die verschmelzung
eines protons mit dem isotop bohr es
hierbei entstehen 3 ebenfalls zweifach
positiv geladener teilchen spannend ist
diese reaktion vor allem weil der
brennstoff relativ leicht verfügbar ist
doch die reaktionen unterscheidet sich
grundlegend von den anderen fusions
reaktionen an denen die fachwelt derzeit
intensiv forscht denn hierbei wird nicht
neutronenstrahlung freigesetzt sondern
energie in form geladener teilchen und
genau das hat nach ansicht des
forschungsteams einige vorteile denn der
neutronen fluss bringt nachteile mit
sich wie etwa die gefahr im umgang mit
ionisierender strahlung das kann also
durch die reaktion mit dem isotop bohr
11 umgangen werden und es gibt einen
weiteren entscheidenden vorteil die
energie geladene teilchen geladene
teilchen kann direkt und somit viel
einfacher in elektrizität umgewandelt
werden bzw sie muss gar nicht
umgewandelt werden es ist elektrizität
sie sind geladen sprich dieses alte
verfahren was immer noch in allem gas
kohle atomkraftwerken genutzt wird dass
man erst wasser heiß macht und dann
verdampfen lässt damit es mit dem
dampfdruck dann in generatoren energie
erzeugt dieses uralte simple und doch
sehr steinzeitliche verfahren das wird
bei diesem verfahren gespart doch es
gibt auch einen entscheidenden nachteil
denn um die reaktion nutzen so können
sind extreme temperatur und druck
bedingungen notwendig also wie auch bei
der bisherigen kernfusion nur noch
extremer gehört doch genau hier könnten
die künstlichen blitze weiterhelfen wie
es in der aktuellen studie aus dresden
heißt denn schnell und stark gepulste
elektrische felder könnten die reaktion
verstärken dazu heißt es vom
forschungsteam unseren berechnungen
zufolge kann ein hinreichend schnelles
und starkes gekürztes elektrisches feld
nicht nur die batterie um tritium fusion
sondern auch die pro turbo reaktion
deutlich verstärken doch die erzeugung
solcher felder ist alles andere als
einfach und stellt eine neue
herausforderung dar doch bereits heute
gibt es anlagen die künstliche blitze
erzeugen können dazu sagt der dresdner
physiker ralf schütz sollte der an der
studie beteiligt war wir können uns das
prinzipiell wie bei einem gewitter
vorstellen bei dem sich die in riesigen
wolke informationen gespeichert der
energie in kürzester zeit druckt auf
engstem raum in der form eines
blitzschlags entlädt weltweit sind
anlagen in bau oder in planung die immer
höhere energien auf innere kürze und
zeit sparen und immer kleinere raum
bereiche konzentrieren sollen doch ist
ist klar derzeit sind noch keine anlage
verfügbar in denen derartig schnelle und
starke künstliche blitze erzeugt werden
können doch das forschungsteam denkt
bereits über einen möglichen ausweg nach
im visier der fachleute das elektrische
feld eines schnell fliegenden alpha drei
teams das dicht am proton vorbei viel
denn dieses könnte dabei wie ein
gepulster elektrisches feld wirken
möglicherweise könnte es so stark zu
stoßen dass das proton die potenzial
barriere von bohr elf durch tunnel dann
würde tatsächlich die fusions reaktion
ausgelöst werden solche einfach teilchen
mit der notwendigen tools energie die
die fachleute als mögliche kandidaten
sehen werden bei der proton power
reaktion tatsächlich sowieso erzeugt
also möglich ist es aber auch diese von
außen einzuschießen ukraine krise so
könnte helfen wir holen flüchtende ich
würde mich wirklich sehr freuen wenn ihr
euch dieses video anschauen würde das
geht um eines der wichtigsten themen in
diesen tagen also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran